what's going on guys this is rob there
are no spoilers in this video for doctor
strange too instead this video is
designed to basically tell you
everything you need to know in order to
get ready to go see doctor strange too
so you're not going to walk in with no
idea of what in the world is going on so
let's start with the multiverse
basically the multiverse came back at
the end of loki and we ended up finding
out that the marvel cinematic universe
existed in one part of the multiverse
that had been isolated think about it
this way imagine you lived in the united
states but you didn't know there was
anything outside the united states and
then one day somebody comes along and
they introduce you to the fact that
there is stuff that exists outside the
united states but you don't know what
else is out there all you know is that
some guy named kang presumably rules it
all that's basically what's going on
with the multiverse of the marvel
cinematic universe and doctor strange
too we will for this example find out
what's going on outside the united
states we'll see what else is going on
in the multiverse now that we are
officially a part of the rest of the
multiverse let's move on to doctor
strange all we really know about doctor
strange in terms of what's going on is
presumably the movie has some kind of an
impact or some kind of uh involvement
with the events of spider-man no way
home only because of the fact that
that's the first real time we'd seen
doctor strange cast a spell that
affected the multiverse all that really
happened for those of you guys who never
saw spiderman no way home is that doctor
strange was going to cast a spell that
would make the world forget that peter
parker was spider-man peter wouldn't
shut the hell up and the spell went awry
instead everybody who knew peter parker
was spider-man was brought into the
marvel cinematic universe the movie
unfolds at the end of the film basically
the spell is corrected or the proper
spell is cast and everybody's made to
forget that peter parker spider-man
after all those individuals who know
that peter parker spider-man are sent
back to their own universes that's about
the extent of the multiverse that we've
seen so far in relation to doctor
strange whether or not this movie ties
into spiderman no way home has yet to be
seen the rumors are saying no other
rumors are saying yes we won't know
until we actually go and see the film
finally let's talk about wanda wanda is
a little more interesting and a little
more complex here exactly how wanda is
involved in this movie is yet to be seen
rumors are saying she's the main villain
other rumors are saying she's somehow
tied to the villain those rumors are
saying that it's cathone or maybe
mephisto or something like that i don't
know people are just looking for reasons
to say that mephisto's in the mcu maybe
he is the main villain no clue we won't
know until we see the movie the
important thing about wanda is this in
the events of infinity war and avengers
in-game we were basically teased or
introduced to this idea that wanda is
seemingly a lot more powerful than we
were initially led to believe which is
great because all she ever really did up
to that point was levitate some stuff
and cast some hexes she was kinda born
but all this really came to a head
during the events of one division and
what we found out is that in the
aftermath of infinity war and avengers
in game when vision had basically died
that was the straw that broke the
camel's back the girl's girl's mind was
already hanging on by a threat and as
soon as vision died she basically went
off the rails and so what ended up
happening here is that in a town called
west view all of this of course taking
place in the one division tv show in
this town called west view wanda had
basically altered reality in order to
give herself the perfect life this
included recreating vision who actually
wasn't really real this also involved
her creating her kids seemingly out of
nowhere now this eventually led to the
introduction of a villain named agatha
harkness who was actually the one that
was keeping an eye on wanda and was
essentially manipulating things behind
the scenes albeit without wanda's
knowledge at the end of one division we
ended up learning that wanda is
basically the prophesized scarlet witch
at the end of the show she also seemed
to step into the full totality of her
power although we didn't quite know
exactly how powerful she was all we knew
is that at the end of the show she had
gotten her hands on a book called the
darkhold which was previously in
possession of agatha harkness and was
now in the possession of wanda the only
real knowledge we have about the
darkhold assuming that anything else any
other appearances in tv form actually
measure up is that it is basically a
book that allows individuals to use
black magic for wanda her source of
magic is seemingly chaos magic what does
that mean basically means she can do
anything at least that's how it works in
the comics now more recently in the
comics we actually learned that the dark
hold is a means by which you can summon
nightmare a super powerful bad guy who
basically grows more powerful feeding on
the dreams of people you can use the
darkhold to summon him into the universe
that's important because one of the more
prominent theories out there is that
nightmare is actually the main villain
in doctor strange too we won't really
know outside of that whatever you've
seen in the trailers that's what
everybody else knows except for the
people who got to see it early curses i
was not one of them
but this should effectively get you
caught up enough to understand what's
going on with doctor strange ii
multiverse of madness for the most part
it's pretty mysterious there are a few
things going on but as far as how
wanda's involved we don't really know uh
we know that like america chavez
basically a girl who can jump between
realities is a part of the movie but we
don't really know much else just
it looks like it's gonna be cool also
the illuminati are in there which is
gonna be really really exciting uh but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end i know it's
super short but uh yeah thank you all
for watching and i will catch you all
later
peace